[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 invités sommaire un
soutien fort derrière françois fillon
nous recevrons sur le plateau suzanne
blanc et lui les républicains à la
mairie de montigny le bretonneux et
responsable du comité de soutien
françois fillon dans les yvelines nous
ferons un plan sur l'action de ce comité
et puis vous entendrez aussi max et leon
les deux héros du palmashow jo du move
est originaire de montfort l'amaury nous
présenteront leur premier film la folle
histoire de max et des eaux il est l'un
des outsiders de la primaire de la
droite et du centre selon les sondages
il frappe il est taxé de 10%
d'intentions de vote au premier tour de
l'élection loin derrière nicolas sarkozy
et alain juppé en tête dans les
intentions de vote mais pour lui comme
le disait récemment aux parisiens les
sondages ne valent pas tripette
et il croit à son destin présidentiel
tout comme susanne blank responsable de
son comité de soutien dans les yvelines
bonsoir dans soir alors est ce que ces
sondages c'est vraiment tripette
moi j'ai toujours entendu qu'un sondage
ne fait pas une élection est ce qu'il ya
de dramatique dans cette histoire c'est
que finalement et françois fillon l'a
rappelé il ya quelques jours lorsqu'il
on a fait un magnifique meeting à
versailles avec un palais des congrès
est plein à craquer il a démarré son
meeting en disant mais qu'est ce que
vous faites là vous tous puisque de
toute façon les les jeux sont faits etc
etc à l'en croire effectivement et les
sondages et tout ce qui se dit
c'est un petit peu dommage parce que ça
laisse à supposer que finalement dans
ces cas là on ne se penche pas sur
le programme du candidat en question on
part du principe qu effectivement il ya
de deux chevaux qui mène la course et
que les autres finalement ne feront que
peu de choses et bien en tout cas on est
beaucoup dans les yvelines et depuis
longtemps avoir décidé que les choses ne
se passeraient pas ainsi c'est pour ça
qu'on se bat depuis plusieurs mois voire
depuis plusieurs années puisque le
démarrage des choses n'a pas commencé
n'a pas commencé avant-hier des choses
ont démarré dès 2012 voilà et bien avant
puisque bien avant j'étais déjà dans le
dans le parti qui avait monté avec avait
monté françois fillon et qui s'appelait
face république qui s'appelle toujours
forces républicaines et qui s'est
appelée france 9 voilà alors quelles
sont vos missions ensemble ce comité que
fonds perçus alors nos missions nos
missions mais ces deux c'est d'avoir
organisé les choses de façon pyramidale
surtout toutes les circonscriptions du
département avec des référents de
circonscription des référents ville
voilà la version ds on va à la rencontre
des français de nos concitoyens tout à
fait on fait du porte à porte ont fait
du tractage on va faire un battage
énorme là qui a commencé qui va se
terminer à la mi novembre
vraiment qui reprend toutes les
propositions de françois fillon et de
son musée moi je vole et les retours
mais ce que effectivement les sondages
titres s'enchaînaient l'abstraction vous
le soutenez les personnes du comité le
soutiennent mais les gens qui regardent
ces sondages ils y croient vous sont ces
petits
moi je ne vais même pas m'attarder sur
les sondages je vais davantage
m'attarder sur le ressenti qu'on les
gens
soit parce qu'ils sont venus un meeting
soit pire ne soit parce qu'ils ont suivi
et là ces jours ci ce fut le cas la
semaine dernière
puisqu'ils étaient sur le grill
de l'initiant jeudi dernier il ya eu
débat bon débat c'est un petit peu
différent mais l'émission de jeudi
dernier a été très révélatrice le
lendemain matin sans même poser de
questions les gens en parlaient en me
disant qu'il était formidable c'est vrai
que finalement on ne connaît pas assez
les choses on n'a pas encore assez lui
peut-être c'est donc c'est là dessus
quand se base c'est vraiment là dessus
et ça n'a pas été juste une personne qui
m'a rencontré ça a été beaucoup de gens
parce qu'après on a communiqué bien sûr
entre nous tous ses soutiens et c'est
vrai que ce ressenti là est très fort et
même au niveau du programme parce que
oui osons le oui toutefois fusion un
programme tout à fait et justement au
niveau du programme bien évidemment bien
évidemment parce que les laisser songeur
mais réformes des réformes mal à se
serrer la ceinture de se serrer la
ceinture
c'est vrai d'une pas mais il ya aussi le
fait que certes il faudra serrer la
ceinture et said le dis donc il s'engage
pas dit la vérité dit la vérité il est
sincère il est honnête il dit qu' un
certain nombre de réformes doivent être
faute d'aidé l'élection présidentielle
et que à mi octobre il faut avoir avancé
le plus possible que ces ministres en
nombre restreint d'ailleurs aurons
autour de deux équipes vraiment de choc
qui
vérifieront que les réformes avancent
que les choses sont bien mises en place
parce que parfois c'est vrai que et ce
n'est la faute de personne c'est comme
ça parce que le temps passe vite parce
que parce que parfois on est freinée par
certaines choses
l'application premier jour voilà
absolument absolument l'application
quasi immédiate d'un certain nombre de
choses pas tout bien évidemment les des
réformes qui ont pas se faire du jour au
lendemain il faudra effectivement ce
quinquennat avec un quinquennat c'est
court voilà que pourtant je les beautés
comme d'autres mais un quinquennat
secours et donc effectivement il faut
être courageux dès le départ d'où aussi
la proposition de faire un référendum
pour faire quelques
réformes majeures 1 et donc ça est pour
et pour justement ne pas connaître ces
blocages de la rue comme comme le dit
françois fillon de manière à pouvoir
avancer faire les choses sans que pour
autant les gens aient peur il ne faut
plus avoir peur on est dans une
situation où on est dans une morosité
tels que on le sent bien autour de nous
on croise tous pleins de gens qui sont
très drôles l agence de l'action ils
sont prêts à saint quentin ou dans les
événements et les réécouter ce message
non j'en suis persuadé bien évidemment
parce que je pense que si on dit au par
exemple aux jeunes gens qui sont sur le
marché de l'emploi la création d'emplois
c'est une chose mais l'emploi permet
d'avoir un meilleur pouvoir d'achat de
pouvoir exister de façon tranquille
d'avoir des projets c'est pas vraiment
plus que en ce moment donc donc
effectivement il faut qu' il y ait du
courage de la part des dirigeants et
puis qui aussi du courage de la part des
des citoyens qui accepte c'est vrai faut
accepter un certain nombre de choses
faut accepter la remise en question des
39 des 35 heures pardon faut accepter un
certain nombre de remises en question
mais il faudra le faire alors c'est je
vais rebondir là dessus parce que il a
été premier ministre de nicolas sarkozy
durant cinq ans ses idées c'est des
idées
détruire les 35 heures passées aux 39
heures c'est des idées qu'on a déjà
entendu
et sap a été fait et on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion public se dit
est-ce que cette fois ça va être fait
pourquoi là cette fois on devrait croire
monsieur fillon alors moi ce que d'abord
il a été tout à fait loyal vis-à-vis de
l'ancien président de la république il y
là il le redit il a été loyal il a été
loyal vis-à-vis de son pays il a fait un
certain nombre de choses quand même
qu'il ne faut pas négliger il a quand
même fait la réforme de france télécom
il a commencé il a fait une avancée
quand même par rapport à la réforme des
retraites
c'est vrai que tout n'a pas été fait
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres événements
aussi qui ont fait que les choses
n'étaient pas aussi simple à résoudre on
est quand même tombé dans une grande
période de crise pendant ces cinq années
du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy et
donc par conséquent c'est vrai qu'il n'a
pas pu avancer totalement mais là
maintenant ce qu'il faut considérer
c'est que c'est un homme d'expérience et
qui donc à coupe bien compris qu
effectivement les réformes c'est de
suite on n'attend pas un an deux ans et
bien que au bout de deux ans c'est trop
tard c'est déjà donc ce que vous me
dites c'est que il a plus d'expérience
ou qu'il avait les
est lié
pas dire ce que je n'ai pas posé la
question
moi je vous dis qu'il a plus
d'expérience et que ça fait tous ceux
qui comme moi une petite expérience à
mon modeste niveau d'élu local on sait
bien qu'il ya des choses
qui ne se font pas d'un coup mais
parfois on sait bien c'est qu'il faut le
faire même si ça fait un petit peu mal
même si on restreint quelques mesures
c'est dur à faire accepter par un
certain nombre de personnes et puis avec
le temps les choses rentrent dans un
espèce de mouvance naturel il faut si on
veut avancer si on veut que ce pays
retrouve toute sa force on retrouve
toute sa force au niveau international
et au niveau européen de toute façon il
faudra en passer par là alors pas
uniquement dans la douleur parce qu'on
va pas dire aux gens voter pour moi que
vous allez voir quand vous allez être
malheureux quand même pas quand même pas
c'est aussi pour donner de l'espoir
justement aux générations plus jeunes de
leur dire voilà si on remet votre pays
en marche comme il faut et bien votre
avenir sera meilleur que moi c'est tout
ce que je souhaite pour mes enfants mes
petits-enfants amber et été et tous les
enfants de ceux que j'aime voilà eh bien
on finira sur cette formule c'est le
message que vous avez fait passer à nos
téléspectateurs en tout cas je vous
remercie madame suzanne blanc merci à
vous
et donc nous passons aux palmas show qui
sort son premier film demain la folle
histoire de max et les ont alors le
pitch deux amis d'enfance qui tente
d'échapper à la seconde guerre mondiale
grégoire ludig et david marsais était à
l'ugc skywest la semaine dernière nous
les avons rencontrés ecoutez-le au micro
de camille lambert
on dort à cela
et après fillon nous nous sommes
l'honneur de la france mais croyez moi
on va la gagner cette guerre
en fait nous comme on vient de la
parodie et qu'on a cherché une idée de
film on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait on
avait envie de faire un film de jean et
la comédie d' aventure c'est un style
qui n'existe plus beaucoup dans le
cinéma français nous on est très fan de
la grande vadrouille la 7ème compagnie
papy fait de la résistance
donc on a eu envie de s'inscrire
humblement en fait dans cette lignée
tout en faisant peut-être des parallèles
un peu plus moderne avec la société
actuelle dire on avait envie de lui même
on avait envie de faire quelque chose
d'ambitieux célèbre patient de passer
par dont des sketches au cinéma on
n'avait pas envie de voir au cinéma
quelque chose qu'on aurait pu faire un
sketch tourner en plus la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est une période qui est très
cinématographique
donc nous qui nous permettait de faire
un film d'époque en costumes nous on
avait plutôt envie de traiter du contenu
de l'intérieur c'est à dire comment les
français réagissent et entre eux donc
c'est un film qui est assez
franchouillard c'est surtout un film qui
a qu'à du recul sur cette période c'est
à dire que dans les années 70 on en
rigolait mai
c'était justement les nazis il y avait
vraiment le côté france contre l'ennemi
on va dire contre le méchant allemand et
là nous on s'est dit bon ben on a un peu
plus de recul donc nous on peut
peut-être se permettre un petit peu plus
de mettre l'accent sur deux ou trois
choses dont on n'a pas vraiment parlé
depuis le moment où on a commencé à
faire des sketches on avait envie de
faire du cinéma mais sauf qu'à 20 ans
était beaucoup plus pratique de
commencer par les sketches puisqu'on
confié personnes et que voilà faire une
vidéo et la mettre sur youtube s'était
finalement beaucoup plus rapide ça fait
quatre ans qu'on travaille sur ce film
écrire un sketch écrire un film c'est
vraiment différent à sketches on l'écrit
en une journée à peu près et le film on
l'a mis deux ans et demi à l'écrire en
laissant reposer parfois justement en
écrivant les folles soirées qu'on avait
avec convenait à côté pour vraiment
laisser mûrir les idées et faire
vraiment évolué les deux personnages
qu'on incarne avoir une vraie histoire
une vraie intrigue et pas faire juste
une succession de sketches en fait parce
que ça c'était pas intéressant nous
avons affaire à des professionnels
et manier l'art du mensonge et du
vieillissement l'apparition
d'un coordo à de tous est rude et crack
à l'époque en même temps ils sont très
forts nous on arrivait bien c'est
intéressant d'avoir une prise de risque
enfin nous à partir du moment où on
passe de la télé au cinéma on s'est dit
faisons un film qui vaille le coup en
fait de faire du cinéma et voilà quand
on a écrit cette histoire on se disait
ben voilà ça c'est cinématographique je
dis pas qu'on a enfin voulait pas
prendre les gens pour des cons coixet et
de deux que les gens viennent et 6 ha
tiens ça c'est exactement ce qu'ils font
la télé en fait s'ils avaient pas
jonathan l'aurais pas fait son job nous
pour nous de lui le real dessus
il nous accompagne et surtout ce qu'on a
fait en fait là et donc ça nous
paraissait évident complètement nous
quand on s'est rencontrés c'est parce
que nous on était venu à la caméra et
que lui était très très bon à la caméra
et qu'il a toujours su me mettre en
scène vraiment bien donc voilà on
pouvait pas faire autrement parce que
des invités oui on a un gros casting on
a beaucoup de second rôle à aucun moment
on a pensé aux acteurs justement pendant
qu'on écrivait le scénario c'est une
fois que le scénario était terminée que
on s'est dit tiens à qui est ce qu'on va
proposer tous ces rôles forcément s'est
tourné vers des gens avec qui on avait
déjà travaillé parce que c'est des gens
qui ont la même sensibilité artistique
et pour servir le film ils sont pas là
pour cabotiner mais ça c'est vraiment
agréable on s'est entouré aussi
d'acteurs comme bernard farcy de l'unpi
nom pareil c'est des acteurs qu'on
admire énormément on rêvait de
travailler avec ces gens parce qu'ils
nous ont aussi donné envie de faire du
cinéma c'est des monstres de la comédie
et voilà quand y est on a su que on leur
a présenté le scénario quand ils l'ont
lu qui nous ont dit ok c'est bon comme
des fous voilà tout simplement et c'est
la fin de ce sept huit invités merci de
nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]